[MUSIC PLAYING]
Whoa.
Did we do it?
So these are what we're blowing
up at the moment.
[POP]
But it's just a glass ball with
a couple of millilitres
of water in it and then
sealed off at one end.
So when you heat them, the
water starts to boil.
But obviously, the water vapour
that you create can't
go anywhere.
The steam builds up, and so
you pressurise the ball.
[POP]
POP
And that pressure keeps on
building and building and
building and building
and building
until the ball explodes.
[POP]
At which point you have a load
of water in there which you've
heated way above its normal
boiling point, 100 degrees,
because it's pressurised.
And as soon as you release
that pressure with the
explosion of the bauble, all
that heat energy that you put
into the water is released as
the water flashes into steam,
and that's the energy that
drives the explosion.
The glass is basically
completely pulverised.
Some of it seems to be embedded
in various places.
Basically, almost embedded
themselves in the
polycarbonate screen.
That's quite hard to do
with polycarbonate.
It must have been going at
quite a rate of knots.
[POP]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This one is definitely the best
we've done in terms of
the way we've seen the glass
fail, and seen the liquid
components start to expand
and immediately boil.
And then also built up
in the component
that's already steam--
you can see through
it for a moment.
But then it starts to condense
into the cloud of water
droplets and become-- it
starts to obscure the
backlighting.
So yeah, it's all over
incredibly quickly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]